hi there I'm Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big fink
podcast since 2008 big thing has been
sharing big ideas and little doses from
some of the most creative thinkers
around on the think again podcast we
take ourselves out of our comfort zone
surprising my guests and me your host we
have unexpected interview clips from big
thinks archives ideas that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss today I'm so happy to be joined
by Professor Eric Kandel of Columbia
University in the year 2000 he won the
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
for pioneering work on understanding how
memory is stored in the brain by
studying a particular type of sea snail
with a relatively simple nervous system
in his recent books he's been pioneering
in a very different way trying to bridge
the gap between the quote unquote two
cultures of the sciences and the
humanities his current book reductionism
in art and brain science continues this
work looking at the ways both modern art
and science reduce complex phenomena
down to their component parts to achieve
new insights and effects welcome to
think again professor Kenda thank you
very much I guess maybe we should start
with the cultural divide between the
humanities and the sciences I mean this
is a very big topic but maybe you want
to start with a bit of an overview of
how that happened yes I mean this was in
the late 1950s and early 1960s CP snow
wrote a series of gave a series of
lectures in wrote a series of essays on
the divide between the humanities and
the sciences he thought that this was an
unbridgeable divide because humanists
and scientists are not only had
different aspirations different goals
but use different methodologies and the
point that I try to make in this book
the overriding theme is that humanistic
aspirations are not unique to people
called humanists but scientists can also
have humanistic aspirations and all
immodesty I can say the the study of
learning in memory
is a humanistic idea we all want to
understand who we are because who we are
is a lot far dependent on what we
remember about ourselves and that has a
biological base the biological bases
memory in addition not only do
scientists have humanistic goals but
artists use empirical scientific
experimental methods and my book shows
several examples of this Jackson Pollock
taking the canvas off the wall and
putting on the floor and dripping on it
this is a completely new approach to
painting right if you could give a
little brief overview of what what you
mean by reductionism because the term
has many meanings some of them purge or
ative but you're not using it in that
way here like maybe you could talk about
what reductionism is and how it you know
broadly it's common to art and science
right reductionism is taking a complex
problem that interests you and taking
one component of that problem and going
into it a great depth so for example on
the cover of my book I have an image by
Roth cow who's a colorful painter and he
is decided that he can convey emotions
most effectively by using color and he
uses stripes of color and many of his
paintings to convey a feeling that is
almost spiritual and as he aged and also
became more depressed the colors changed
became darker in a Rothko Chapel they're
dark Browns and blacks and Stilley
conveys a powerful mood in this way so
this clearly is a reductionist approach
has chance of doing many things besides
colors accuse figuration and addition
color but it drops out figuration
focuses only on color and simplifies the
color pattern and yet we get a powerful
response to it and this is yeah correct
me if I'm wrong but the way I'm thinking
about it the goal of reductionism in
science at least as you describe it in
the book specifically using the example
of your work with sea snails you know
you are trying to understand the complex
phenomenon of
by looking at a relatively simple
nervous system but your goal is to
understand that phenomenon whereas the
artists that you describe what they're
trying to do seems to be less about
understanding maybe then about getting
at some more immediate experience or
provoking some kind of response in
themselves or in the viewer could you
speak to that of it yes I mean you
described it perfectly reductionism need
not simply solve a scientific problem
although in a sense
every artist solves scientific problems
along the way but it may be that of the
range of emotional experiences the
artist will only focus on some rather
than others in order to go into it in
some depth so for example I mean the
history of art from djaro to 1850 to
Claude Monet was figuration the whole
idea of art was to deceive the viewer
into thinking that when they were
looking at a flat surface they were in
fact seeing a 3-dimensional world and
the whole artistic capability critically
involved trying to develop perspectives
etc that gives you the sense of three
dimensionality modern arts reduce that
why not accept the fact that we work in
a flat surface and let's do the most we
can with the flat surface and bring out
new stuff and what they're driving at
though as you described it in the book
and you quote a number of these artists
but they seem to be driving at most of
them is trying to get a more immediate
experience of the sublime but but not to
demystify it in any way and that I
wonder whether that's sort of the heart
of this cultural divide sometimes
between the art the humanities and the
sciences that you know science seeks to
demystify whereas the the arts at least
I don't know that they do I don't know
that they're using reduction as well I
think you're absolutely right I don't
think the artist tries to demystify it
that is not the purpose of reduction the
purpose of reduction is to increase the
mystery I mean one of the wonderful
things about abstract
painting if we look at a de Koning or
look at a Jackson Pollock is because the
information is often ambiguous it forces
us to fill in the detail and I describe
this in the book in terms of top-down
processing we rely on our free
association our memory our previous
experience to fill in the detail of
ambiguity and that means that you
recruit the behold of the participant in
the creative act this actually goes back
to Allen's regal and took umbrage and
turns Chris who pointed out that when
you and I look at the same painting we
see it somewhere differently what does
that mean that each of us is recreating
in our own brain the image that we're
looking at that is the beholder
undergoes in a very modest way a
creative experience that parallels in a
very modest way the creativity of the
artist and why is that interesting I
don't know whether you've had that
experience but certainly I find when I
have the most modest creative idea it
gives me a great deal of pleasure and I
think one of the things that is so
pleasurable about abstract art for those
people who respond to it is that it
gives you lots of room for your own
creativity so now what's interesting
though with these abstract painters and
not all the painters you described in
the book are abstract I mean Chuck Close
you use this abstraction to build up you
know portraits but is that in a way
there they seem to be ceding some of the
some of the control of the artist over
to the the B holders share like
increasingly by saying absolutely right
right the share is has a more prominent
feature in abstract art than it has in
figured of art and this is one reason
why some people don't like abstract off
too much work for them but other people
who enjoy this get a lot of satisfaction
out of it I guess where I was going with
that is that it seems an unusual move
for an artist like our stereotype of
artists is that they can be somewhat of
control freaks you know wanting total
over the process and over how the thing
is perceived I think that's definitely
true of writers to some extent but for
them to make this move of you know
giving more and more over to the viewer
is an interesting I get your point and
you're 100% right
it is only one dimension of it I think
they are control freaks I think that
Pollock and de Kooning are
perfectionists and you know that I
discussed this one painting that
Rosenberg who was a Shapiro I guess
professorship at Columbia came to visit
him and saw this and said you know this
is a wonderful painting and decoding
didn't want to release the painting
didn't think it was ready to go because
he still felt he couldn't prove it and
he told him this is a masterpiece get it
out right now
so I mean they are very much control
freaks but they control freaks in the
way they control ambien and they're
controlling I guess their own sort of
their own experience their own right
right right right then and it's been
it's up to the viewer that's that's
interesting okay well I think that might
be a good moment for us to transition
into the the second part of this yes
this is this first one is Janna Levin
who's an astrophysicist and the video is
called three visionary scientists who
embraced limitations to have creative
outbursts
I became interested in this phenomenon
of Constraints inspiring creative
outbursts and if you look at the last
century there were three really profound
examples of that I would say the
earliest that I found incredibly
interesting was the limit of the speed
of light leading Einstein to the theory
of relativity where a lot of other
scientists wanted to remove the limit
they wanted to say there is no limit to
the speed of light that doesn't make any
sense that's impossible
Einstein actually despite the word
relativity adhere to a very strict
absolute and that absolute was the speed
of light he took that to be his guiding
constraint and by sticking to it rigidly
he said I'll give up anything else but
the speed of light and by doing so he
gave up on the absolute nature of space
and time so I mean that's just much
harder to let go of intuitively but it
was right
so she's talking about embracing
limitation like how limitation can
actually push science forward have you
found that to be true in your own work
well I mean in in a sense it isn't quite
a reductionist approach but it's
focusing on one thing to the exclusion
of others in a sense and certainly if
you look at the history of go beyond
memories to take a larger problem if you
look at the explosion in understanding
the biology of life that came with the
discovery of genes by Mendel and then
later on by Thomas and Morgan realizing
their genes around chromosomes and then
the discovery the genes are made out of
DNA then a fabulous Watson Crick
discovery about the structure of DNA of
the gene I mean these are all focusing
on the gene to exclusion of carbohydrate
metabolism lipid metabolism everything
else those are secondary processes that
derive from genetic control of cellular
processes so I think in a sense this is
not a universal strategy but a common
strategy often there are major variables
that if you understand them other things
will follow more readily I guess it was
Karl Popper I think it was the who spoke
about paradigm shifts and how
essentially science proceeds by people
laboring in specific trenches for long
periods of time and then either you have
a visionary who breaks things open or or
or those limitations of focus end up
leading to breakthrough yeah I mean Karl
Popper has been very important in my
field in the following way Karl Popper
felt you can't prove anything in science
or you can do is disprove and that
turned out to be a very important
historical insight there was a guy by
the name of Jack Eccles who was a major
major person my field a major student of
synaptic transmission okay
and he thought synaptic transmission
between nerve cells was mostly
electrical and with time it became
clearer and clearer that this was likely
to be wrong
and echoes became despondent at that
time I think I think he was in Australia
I forget where he was but he went to the
Faculty Club and he bumped into Papa and
they became friends and explain to him
why he was depressed and Papa said
that's ridiculous
you can't ever prove anything all you
can do is to disprove it go back into
the lab and disprove yourself show that
you were wrong that it's not electrical
that it must be chemical and that's
exactly what he did I guess yeah I guess
I would be interested in hearing kind of
as an adjunct to this what you know in
in your field and the work that in the
work that you do on on memory and brain
science what are the intractable
problems right now that people are
finding themselves bumping up against
that if they could solve them it would
be a major you know move for what seemed
to be the GNAT frontiers right now for
brain science we're trying to see for
example what is responsible for the
reliability of memory in the one hand
and it's extraordinary unreliability and
the other you know often we have the
feeling we remember something when we
don't right we miss remember it and this
is why testimony in court is so
unreliable a single observer remembering
an event has a finite and not too small
chance of being wrong not by being
dishonest by just miss perceiving
misremembering right so memory is not
you know stamping something into a book
and you never have to worry about it
it's often modified as a result of
subsequent experiences without our being
aware of it so trying to figure out what
controls that and how we can get a
better idea into the core of the memory
process is a very active part of the
field that's interesting do you think
that that may have something to do I
mean from a cognitive standpoint that
that may have something to do with kind
of the pragmatics of memory like what
what it is that we actually need to
remember in order to survive versus what
we don't I mean that we're I think it
deals with the pragmatics of memory I
think it deals with the pragmatics of
the brain so I remember this
seshu for example we're having right now
and it's possible that I'm sitting down
one day listening to a similar
conversation and I may confuse that
second conversation at a subsequent time
as being part of the first conversation
right Yuri experienced the initial
memory and you often bring to bear on it
some of the subsequent experiences
associated with the second Bryce sitting
without just the first but possibly
because those things are being stored in
us I mean I'm not asking you to
speculate on science that hasn't been
done yet but possibly because those
memories are stored in similar areas and
we're conserving space or something
that's right and it can be activated in
different ways and also when a memory is
recalled particularly the first few
times it's sensitive to disruption and
distortion so those things can interfere
with the long-term fidelity of the
memory story how does that disruption or
a distortion happen I mean like so when
I'm recalling the memory the first few
times and it be the description is only
in a sense that the memory is fixed but
the structures that fix it become
unglued for a second for a short period
of time so the memory if perturbed can
be also if something like so let me let
me put it to you this way when you form
a memory it's a short-term memory and it
doesn't persist but if you train
repeatedly you form a long-term memory
and that long-term it consists of growth
of new synaptic connections and those
synaptic connections require new protein
synthesis during a certain critical
period that protein synthesis is
sensitive to disruption and you can lose
the growth of new synaptic connections
despite the fact that they've occurred
because the synthesis is that ongoing
after a while that no longer happens but
in the early stages of long-term memory
storage it's susceptible to disruption
and disruption can come from like other
memories or ambient settings happening
around you other experiences of the
moment yeah interesting interesting okay
well I think I think on that note let's
let's move on to the second surprise
clip this is Harvard psychologist susan
david on the psychology of defeating
fear
low self-esteem and hate live in the
mind when we have politicians who are
effectively demagogues
who are inspiring fear in us that fear
leads to very particular and relatively
predictable responses when we are
fearful there is this idea in
psychological research of mortality
salience that when our mortality is
threatened when someone says oh this
group of people is out to get you and we
feel that we are actively being
threatened we are more likely to
stereotype we are more likely to respond
to messages that we hear time and time
again even if they are against our
values as somehow making sense to us how
do we protect ourselves against this
Daniel Kahneman describes system 1
thinking and system 2 thinking system 1
thinking is the intuitive response that
can sometimes arise out of fear system 2
is the deliberate thoughtful examination
of what is this person saying is it
aligned with how I really want to be
when we are able to step back from our
fear we are able to come to a place
where we are ultimately protected from
the demagoguery message
okay so we're talking about demagoguery
and fear and I guess an immediate point
of reference in America in 2016 leaps to
all of our minds immediately yes I have
had thrilling experiences like this oh I
would like to hear about that yes I'm
Jewish
and I was born in Vienna Austria and
when I was nine years old right Hitler
marched into Austria and was received by
the Viennese in Vienna where I was
living with open arms and immediately
people who had been our friends turned
away from us and essentially became our
enemies and that's because Hitler had
fantastic anti-semitic propaganda and he
got this propaganda in part from an
earlier v's Hitler was in Vienna in 1906
1910 and the mayor of Vienna at that
time was a guy called Carlo eiga and Lou
aigis was a terrific orator a tremendous
campaigner
he wasn't even all that anti-semitic he
had Jewish friends he would say I
determine who's a Jew but he had a
fantastic way of saying the reason you
don't have any money is because the Jews
are taking it away from you so it scared
the hell out of people particularly
those that didn't have jobs convincing
them that the Jews by charging high
prices by creating works of art that
expensive it said that God knows how
many reasons we're destroying the
quality of their life so he created this
environment of fear to which people
responded and Hitler wrote in my camp I
learned more from Luigi how to run a
campaign than anybody else and fear is
of course a traditional way in which
people build up opposition to one force
in order to get support for another and
I found it very hard for the longest
time to understand how people can listen
to hide and Mozart and Beethoven one day
and beat up the Jews the next I wonder
what that did you know for you to you in
terms of your thinking about humans at
that early age to see that transition
happen almost
overnight like do you do you have
conscious memories of that of course
yeah absolutely
my brother had built a shortwave radio
set and we were listening to it as
Hitler marched into Vienna and in
Heldman Platz 200,000 people came out
and cheered him like mad no it dominated
the scene I walked the streets two days
later and the classmate of mine came up
to me said Kandel I'm never to speak to
you again
that was horrible and and they you ask
yourself the question what is it that
separates the good guys from the bad
guys
and you come to the conclusion I think
the current campaign in the United
States illustrates that that every one
of us is capable of good and of evil
Reinhold Niebuhr once said the
capability of people for good makes
democracy desirable the capability for
evil makes democracy necessary that's
well said and I recently read a book
called machete season and it was about
what happened in Rwanda and it was
primarily based on interviews with these
people who had been just you know
workers ordinary people living in Rwanda
who then became the kind of soldiers of
this campaign this massacre against
their tribal enemies and just the sort
of mundanity of the way in which they
described going out every day to hunt
other people was extraordinary yeah yeah
absolutely
Hannah Arendt call this the banality of
evil well it's a little bit I mean I was
very irritated with her use of that this
was about Eichmann in Jerusalem evil is
not banal and many of the people
particularly in Iceman's case he was a
major force he was not a follower he was
a leader but he was able to bring many
people along no that's right that's
right there are those people at the top
who are very conscious and calculating
and aware of what they're doing I mean I
I don't know I can't you know I'm not a
psychologist but I so I can't say
whether a Donald Trump is you know
personally aware or conscious enough of
what he's doing to be
considered truly evil but with his
followers you you want to look at it and
you want to say these people are crazy
these people are stupid but obviously
that's not the case for all of them
obviously obviously our brains are
vulnerable to to this kind of
manipulation I think that this is what
the Trump movement is shown is you would
never think that a movement like this
could succeed that the United States and
it's amazing how far it has gone
although it is clearly fading and that
is that there were people who were
dissatisfied with certain aspects of our
lifestyle to whom he appeals and he does
it by phobia of strangers you know
preventing people from coming into the
country etc etc etc do you have any
thought do you have any thoughts or
insights from your vantage point I mean
of having experienced what you did as a
kid and seeing this happening in America
now into sort of what would be a better
way to engage the people that are
following Trump now like what is America
not doing I mean I know you're not
trying to run the country but I'm being
I'm not sure I can I mean I'm so
startled by the success I think the case
could be stronger and would be stronger
if Hillary ran a campaign a little bit
better and if she had run her life a
little bit better I mean you know she
realized that she's interested in public
office and I think the whole email thing
could have been completely finesse
moreover this accepting large sums of
money from companies for giving lectures
when she's gonna run for public office
and realize the question is gonna rise
is she gets a half a million dollars or
whatever she did for a lecture is she
gonna feel beholden to those people I
you would you would think so I mean you
and I of course would never be somebody
only got a half a million dollars but
Hillary Clinton who how does one know
yeah I mean it's it that's right I mean
even if she is somehow immune front to
their influences it's hard to preserve
the illusion of neutrality I think it's
essential yeah I think she made mistakes
and I think one of the reasons Trump is
more successful than it might have been
is that Hillary although I her and I
think she probably make a very good
president did not handle herself in her
public life in an ideal fashion she did
not handle herself the way of Obama's
handled himself which i think is
extraordinary sure but at the same time
there just seems to be so much anger or
so much fear here and like I it's hard
for me to believe the Trump just
instilled that in everybody I mean
obviously there were large numbers of
people concerned about immigrants taking
their jobs and you know that that have
these well I mean did you know our
country is not perfect if you look at
the number of people who have billions
and see where taxes they pay compared to
people earning forty fifty thousand
dollars or eighty thousand dollars it's
amazing you know there are problems in
this country do I complain not too
seriously I think this is you know
heaven on earth
I've had a wonderful life here yeah well
I mean I'd like I'd like it to remain so
for coming generations so hopefully we
can avoid Trump getting elected or any
repeat thereof because it just doesn't
bode well for for our future yeah yeah I
mean the price of democracy is constant
vigilance
I mean I'm repeating cliches but right
right right no but this is new all right
so let's move on to the third and I do
good yeah this is George muster on the
strangeness of physics and telepathy
the whole progress of physics is to
start with our everyday experience and
to analyze it and look at it and look
for deviations from it so the very
nature of actually really all the
Natural Sciences but certainly a physics
is to really get away from our
experience so the things physics comes
up with are just kind of our weird
subatomic particles we can't see them
directly at least but we know they're
there we can actually do thought
experiments about the things we do see
and deduce their existence
so already even with just that amid
example we've gotten ventured beyond our
direct experience and a hundred years
ago or so people doubted the existence
i've atom is a lot of loan of sub atomic
particles nonlocality spooky action at
the distances very much in that in that
mold it's taking us yet further away
from our experience and therefore we
expect it to be weird it shouldn't be
weird
that's why physics is flattened and as
other scientists have said you expect it
in fact if the theory isn't weird
you kind of doubt it because you might
worry that your own biases are intruding
into the into the theory and causing you
to think the world is a certain way when
you're not listening to the way the
world actually is so weirdness is in a
sense a test of a theory
I mean I'd largely but not completely
agree with it
I don't think physics necessarily has to
be weird and that weirdness with me is
not a test of the reliability but
certainly it deals with phenomenon that
we do not intuitively think about all
the time at least people outside of
physics don't think about it and it
deals with many things that are
invisible have to be inferred and some
day biology will reach that level at the
moment that's not the case
biology doesn't they're all deal with
things that are weird I mean it's some
weird things come out of it but it tries
to explain you know living processes
that make intuitive sense and we want to
understand them and I'm more profound
and you can you say more about what you
mean by some day biology make me get
there why would that happen well I think
we probably want to understand things
and a deeper level right now if we
understand the level of of molecules we
think we're making a great deal of
progress but we may want to make it you
know on an even more profound level
unlevel of electron movement or
something like that we've seen this all
the time as a matter of fact take theory
which has such an important role in
physics it didn't have an important role
in biology for the longest time but I
came along there was a fair amount of
Theory going on but it was mostly
Milwaukee right because you can make it
theory about anything you want to have a
theory about memory I give you five
theories about memory you know people
were coming up with theories but they
were not testing them right this has
changed now theories had a major
comeback in the last 15 years this was
true for a long time in physics as well
right I mean they had all these theories
that they weren't able to test without
the particle reactors and so on so so
from the standpoint of laypeople it was
like what on earth are they yes
talking about true but but but in brain
science it was a little bit different
because they could test it but they
didn't think of doing it they didn't
think it was necessary I say to test the
theory but the fact is we can develop a
theory for anything right unless you say
now this is a prediction let's run an
experiment to test that prediction which
is what's going on right now does brain
science you talked a little bit about
but in your book about how brain science
and psychology have somewhat merged in
oh the tremors impact on one another and
again again this is an area in which
people outside of psychology even in the
early stages psychologists thought that
these primitive guys from brain science
wanna beat us up they want to swallow
the field and that's not you you cannot
do biology of the mind without being a
psychologist
I mean psychologists described many of
the obvious central phenomenon classical
conditioning perception sensation all of
these things were studied in very
reliable ways in psycho physical terms
of movie now I want to do is add the
biology to it and give it a new depth a
new level of understanding
it's a beautiful case of coming together
in fact I would go further than this I
would say there had been a sequence of
mergers first there was a merger between
cognitive psychology and brain biology
sort of a new biology of mind but at the
same time this was occurring there was
Watson and Crick and Gilbert and all
these people coming along developing
molecular biology and so the approaches
of molecular biology cloning gene
sequencing them figuring out their
function through mutations became
applicable to the brain so we can now
test many of these ideas with powerful
molecular approaches knock out this gene
get rid of this particular protein so
this put brain science and a completely
new level that's interesting I mean
going back to the test case of
psychology and brain science that I that
is kind of a beautiful model I supposed
for the reconciliation of the sciences
and the humanities in a way because well
psychosis comas general fairness by the
time we got around to it
was no longer part of the humanities
right brain sciences part of the matters
I mean it is a humanistic discipline but
psychology at that time cognitive
psychology was empirical laboratory
experimental discipline right right
right right no I guess I guess something
you have like theory of personality and
that's something else
the the psychodynamics of it that's
still soft in fact you know my I was
interested in psychoanalysis I wanted to
become an analyst at one point and I'm
glad I didn't go that direction because
psychoanalysis is dying and one of the
reasons is thawing is it has not become
empirical right and yet we do have these
big questions you know about like about
meaning identity what it means to live a
good and authentic life absolutely and
and you can ask him for there is a guy
called Aaron Beck who developed
cognitive behavioral psychology I don't
know whether you know this about he was
interested in testing one of Freud's
ideas Freud had the idea that people who
were depressed are angry they first
expressed the anger toward others they
feel guilty about this they may
internalize it feel angry with
themselves then I caused the depression
so Aaron Beck thought he would test this
and he tested by using the Royal Road to
the unconscious which is dreaming so
listen to the dream lifers with
depressed patients and did an all sound
as if this was the problem with them
what they all sounded like is that they
had a low image of themselves here this
guy was a famous radio interviewer and
he thought of himself as being you know
so-so a guy was very successful in
business thought it was a failure at
home low image and as he began to
address himself to this issue of low
image saying you know why do you think
you like this show look your family
really enjoys you and appreciate you he
began to alter his behavior any
cognitive behavior therapy developed so
what Aaron Beck did is to write a
cookbook so you and I could do the same
thing I say NES are the people to do
this and they were able to get the same
results and they needed a miracle
outcome studies with controls showing
that mild and moderate depression are
significantly helped by cognitive
behavior therapy severe not so much but
synergistic with antidepressants it
works very well so you can take these
concepts and make them scientific right
it just hasn't happened by and large in
psychoanalysis we don't know if it works
under what circumstances and how it
works
and that's got to come if it's going to
survive at all okay well Eric Kandel it
has been wonderful talking to you today
thank you so much
for for spending your time on this show
this has been a lot of fun and and to
our audience I would strongly recommend
professor Kendall's new book
reductionism in art and brain science it
is fascinating
beautifully written the science has
explained incredibly clearly and it's
full of gorgeous reproductions of modern
paintings thank you so much for your
time professor Kendall oh thank you for
inviting me this is very enjoyable for
me and that's it for this week's episode
of think again I've been talking lately
on this show to a lot of artists and
writers and it's really refreshing to
speak to a scientist especially one who
has lived through so many of the major
developments in the past century in
science and art and has so much to say
about them I hope you enjoyed that
conversation as much as I did and we
have lots of amazing things lined up
this fall it's gonna be a really really
interesting fall I am going on a brief
and much-needed vacation but the show
will be here and I hope to see you back
here next week